hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute thriller of a game from the
final round of this year's reykjavik
open so it's round nine gookash vs
pragananda uh and uh it's just a
spectacular game you guys will enjoy it
uh so let's dive straight into it and
then we're gonna discuss a little bit
more about the event uh so glucose has
the white pieces and he opens with d4
and the situation in the top is still
very unclear so anyone could really win
win first place if you if you're not
closely paying attention to the tie
breaks so of course they both really
want to win this so glucose plays d4 we
have knight to f6 c for e6 knight to c3
and prague goes for the nimzo indian
defense with bishop to b4 and we've had
a couple of games that we analyzed
recently where the older continuation a3
was played sort of allowing black to
double wide spawns here with bishop
captures on c3 but glucose continues in
the normal line with e3
we have castles by prague bishop to d3
and now striking in the center with the
d5 and now c captures on d5 uh usually
knight to f3 is played but it's i guess
a matter of preference whether you uh
prefer the the exchange on d5 or not so
first we have the trade and now a3 uh
asking black what do you do with the
bishop so prague moves it back the ship
to d6 and now queen to c2 nicely
developing putting pressure on the h7
pawn
and the position has been reached before
and interestingly vidit had this
position both against arunian and
against richard rapport and against
rapport he played a6 uh and lost that
game and against taranyan he played c6
and lost that game and interestingly
both a6 are and c6 are the top moves
recommended by the engine uh but here
prague actually plays b6 it is a move
not recommended by the engine and uh the
engine doesn't really uh like this move
for black so well it doesn't give white
a clear advantage uh here probably
saying this will be a very nice surprise
for glucage because he might not have
analyzed this move so here goku says all
right you are preparing to develop the
light core bishop you are adding more
support to this c5 push so i will block
it i will i will just play b4 uh which
is a move that is uh well whenever you
play it it's usually a good move uh but
probably uh nonetheless strikes with c5
and okay b characters in c5 b captures d
captures uh and the bishop captures on
c5 and this leaves sprague with the
isolated d-pawn and now some people like
playing with the isolated deep on some
players i hate it some players very much
enjoy playing against the isolated pawn
uh so it's
again a matter of preference so knight
to f3
and now rook to e8 here uh
castles and we have bishop the g4
attacking the knight here and uh
proceeds with rook to d1 he says i don't
mind if you open up my king side i have
more than enough compensation for this
and glucage is right this is the
absolute top move recommended by the
engine so prague opens up the king side
bishop captures on f3 g captures and now
bishop back to d6 you don't want this
bishop here even though okay white for
the moment doesn't have any good
discoveries even if knight captures
queen can capture the bishop will be
defended but still bishop to d6 you
don't want to distention and also you
will uh probably use the bishop to
attack the white king so here bishop to
b2
uh just uh grabbing hold of this
diagonal now you can see that glucose
bishop's pair is definitely fully
operational bishop to e5 by prague
countering
dark square bishop on b2 and now comes
bishop to b5 attacking the rook on eight
here you could actually go for an
all-out trade uh but it's unclear
whether lukas could play for a win if he
does this knight captures on d5 is
definitely on the table uh forcing a
whole series of trades bishop captures
on b2 queen captures knight captures and
e5 now bishop e4 threatening to pick up
the knight queen to g5 check king the h1
and not knight to b6 so we will give up
the rook on a8 but of course there is no
rush we can play rook to g1 now if the
black queen moves to silly square we can
check made the black king so of course
queen e5 we have to block this offer a
trade of queens let's say captures
captures and now bishop captures an a8
knight captures and now let's say rook a
to d1 threatening some chuck made in two
moves but now knight to c7 and black
will defend against checkmate and uh
okay now you have this position where
white is up upon black has two knights
for a rook uh so white would definitely
be better here would it be enough to
push for a win uh it's hard to say
so uh after bishop to e5 lucas goes for
the bishop to b5 idea now threatens the
rook here knight beat the d7 blocking by
developing and only now knight captures
and e5 so this ensures that white keeps
the tension and doesn't trade off
absolutely everything so here bishop
captures on b2 queen captures and now
what do you play here well now white is
kind of clearly better aside that um
okay his king is a little loose here but
there's no real way for prague to start
attacking the white king and here prague
plays rook to e5 and now
it's already very very tricky because it
seems like you can definitely win some
material here let's say you play knight
captures on f6 with check you can't
capture back with the knight you're
going to lose the queen if you capture
back with the g pawn still we pick up
the knight as it's attacked twice uh and
if queen captures on f6 then let's say
we play rook captures on d7 it's kind of
okay completely winning for white but
not really rook g5 check and you lose
the queen on b2 so it's a very tricky
idea rook to e5 so glucage goes for the
absolute cleanest way to keep advantage
bishop captures on d7 rook captures and
e5 rook calculus on the e5 knight
captures on d5 and now just bishop back
to h3 so uh he keeps the extra pawn uh
and it's a bishop against the knight uh
with the white king still being uh still
kind of feeling the the the
the draft but uh okay nothing wrong with
that here and here we have knight to b6
a very precise idea by prague uh because
if you just start developing pieces
let's say you try something like rook to
b8 okay you gain a temp on the queen
queen d2 now you're threatening e4 and
after the queen moves let's say queen f6
rook to d1 and already it's very very
hard for black to play this so instead
prague first place knight to b6 we have
queen to e5 uh it's uh guess wants to
centralize his queen which is always a
great idea other moves to consider are
maybe uh f4 taking away the g5 square
from the black queen also just uh rook
to c1 stopping rook to c8 but okay uh he
goes for the centralization move first
queen to e5
now comes queen to d2 by prague
uh and okay it's a very active black
queen but not much for the black queen
to do there so here f4
and now queen to e2
what can what can goku do here he of
course continues development rook the c1
uh and now we have queen to d3 uh
attacking the pawn here as now that the
rook moved the pawn is no longer
defended queen to c3 defending the pawn
and offering a queen trade and prague
says all right let's trade queens uh
even though yeah you are up material but
trading queens here would not be all
that impressive and now you have to
defend the pawn after rook day one it's
uh well okay you're up a pawn but uh
it's very ugly uh this pawn is on a dark
square so the bishop will not be able to
go after that pawn and the knight and
rook will both uh uh well go after the
a3 pawn so
very unlikely that white will be able to
push for a win here so instead we have
queen to c7 putting pressure on this
rook
and of course you don't want to play
something like rook to c8 the bishop
covers that square but also even if it
didn't we could just give up the queen
for a nice checkmating idea so here we
have h6 creating a little breeding room
for the king and now queen captures on
a7 uh so just grabbing that pawn uh and
uh okay now prague is completely lost
but they don't say it for nothing when
there is a knight there's a chance and
of course prague starts using his knight
knight to d5 we often say uh that
knights are tricky bastards and this
game kinda kind of proves that uh idea
so bishop to f1 chasing away the queen
queen the g6 with check bishop to g2 now
and knight the c3 so the first tricky
move with the knight is here uh of
course the knight cannot be captured uh
if you capture the knight then rook to
d1 is just mate in one the bishop cannot
move uh and if you do nothing then we're
going to play knight to the e to check
and fork your king and rook here so here
rook to f1 so okay maybe a passive
square for the rook but still white is
completely winning here nothing wrong
with that and after a move like knight e
to check we can just move the king there
is no real continuation for black here
so here prague plays queen to d3
uh and now comes a4 and goku says
there's really nothing to worry about
here i'm just going to push my pawn and
win the game as that's what the position
requires so rook to d6 now we okay now
we have more control over the a6 square
uh but also we are preparing to shift
this rook to the king side rook g6 and
attack the white king so okay a5 still
no threats here we have rook to g6 and
now we have king to h1 uh but first we
have to unpin it's uh it's uh just a
safety precaution that has to be made
and you have to be careful a move like
queen to d4 it seems like you're
offering a queen trade knight to check
picks up the queen so you don't want
something like this to happen so okay
king to h1 again white is completely
winning here king to h7 uh prague also
gets his king to a safer square we have
queen to d4 now offering a queen trade
is definitely an idea and queen back to
f5 offering a knight here but
uh this knight again cannot be captured
if you capture the knight now then we
just play rook captures on g2 and it's
either a quick draw or a very long draw
because if the rook is captured then we
just play queen g4 check and we have a
draw by perpetual here so there's that
for prague and if you don't capture the
rook which of course you don't have to
you could play queen to e5 or for a
queen trade first then we just move the
queen back and again you cannot capture
the rook we still have the same idea so
queen the e for check now uh attacking
the king and the rook we have to block
with rook to g6 and now okay now white
can continue pushing but it's still
unclear if white will have enough let's
say f5 we challenge the rook rook to a6
now and now okay rook to a1 uh but it
seems that black kind of defended here
there's not much for
for you to do here
uh so okay after queen to f5 we have
queen to e5 declining the night offer
but attacking the queen but after this
move uh
is no longer winning there are a couple
of ideas that he could have tried for
example h3 here uh completely seals the
deal and there are no more weaknesses in
white's camp that would be just uh just
devastating for for prague the problem
is they were both around the one minute
mark maybe even below that so they were
both playing an increment uh so after
queen to e5 now prague just placed queen
to g4 he threatens checkmate and now the
only way to defend the position for
white is to play bishop to e4 yes you
are still guarding the g2 square so
don't get checkmated and you also skewer
the the black rook and here let's say
knight captures any four queen captors
we're going to play queen e2 and that's
enough for a draw we attack the rook
here once the rook moves to attack the
pawn of course we can capture but we
don't even have to we can just continue
harassing the rook and now okay let's go
back a draw
however after queen to g4 rook to g1 was
played and sadly for for gukesh uh he
played the entire uh game pretty much
with engine like precision so after
prague made that uh b6 attempt all of
his moves uh were brilliant and they
very quickly brought glucage to uh to a
winning position however uh the last two
moves in time trouble uh brought his
position to a draw first and then to a
completely lost position but only if
prague finds the only winning move here
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning idea for prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
oh incredibly tricky maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is knight to d1 that's the good
stuff this is what prague played and
after knight to d1 on move 37 it was in
this position that lucas resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so devastating devastating loss for
gurkish who really played brilliantly
the entire game and then
last two moves he just collapsed
completely uh the problem is now how do
you defend knight captures an f2 a
smothered mate a beautiful smuttered
mate
and the only way for the queen to defend
it is to go here but the knight also
covers that square so we kind of could
also use this for a thumbnail
if you move the rook uh somewhere to f1
to to defend the f2 pawn then you're no
longer guarding the bishop then a queen
captures the bishop and g2 is checkmate
and of course if you play something like
h3 to give your king some breeding room
then we just play knight captures and
have to check king h2 and now queen to
g3 will be checkmate so incredible stuff
uh brilliantly played by both of them
prague did surprise him he made him
waste time
he found all the correct continuations
but
time trouble it's you know it's uh it's
always a mystery what can happen there
and uh well sometimes you blunder
sometimes your opponent blunders uh but
you know uh all in all knights are
tricky bastards uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys uh enjoyed it big uh
congratulations to pragananda who not
only wins this game but the entire
reykjavik open 2022 here are the final
standings of the tournament after night
rounds so you can see that pragananda
wins with seven and a half points uh and
there are so many people on seven points
you can see um armadam andersen greta
son abimanu mishra
and even gurkish who finished 17th with
six points if he if he had won this game
he would also be on seven points so it
would be
complete madness at the top by prague by
winning this game uh he is clean he he
wins it with clear first seven and a
half points so big congratulations to
prague on yet another uh spectacular
tournament victory uh so yeah uh that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it if
you have any other favorite games from
the reykjavik open do you have that
suggestion i would be more than happy to
share them with everyone uh i would like
to thank lionel alexandrino that the
dude lb usfd efri uh sagittopivala and
francisaire for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day